and we have the white pieces here
against henry
c y e all right i want to do something
interesting
let's start with d4 and
actually let's not do something
interesting
let's play d4 and he's gone g6
so if we go e4 this transposes into the
modern
but i want to play it in the spirit of
one to d4
so what does that mean what move does
that entail if you want to play this in
the spirit of a d4 opening
what is the key move that entails
the difference
that entails the difference c4 c4 is
correct
and now we go e4 so that's what people
have to understand
if we have the knight on c3 and the pawn
on c2
then that's an e4 opening that's the
modern
this is the king's indian or a version
of the king's indian
because white's pawn is on c4 rather
than c2
you might look at this and say wait a
second why would we not play c4 doesn't
that control more of the center but that
gets back into
what i've talked about from the very
start which is that controlling more of
the center isn't necessarily a good
thing
let's develop our knight uh it's a very
fine balance
neither option is better they're just
different positions and he goes e6
this is not good this is not good at all
um if you guys remember from the five
minute speeder and i told you
on several occasions and i told i
screamed at charlie actually
that the combination of these two moves
is a very dangerous one particularly
if you follow up with the fiance because
oh
look at this square look at this square
if only we could get a
yo knight on the square well what's
stopping us nothing let's go e5 9496
we're cutting corners a little bit
because we're not developing
but this is so important that we're
willing to put the development on hold
to at least gain control of the square
and this is another thing which people
struggle with
i think a lot of you would play knight
d6 instantly but knight d6 is not the
best move
and the reason why is because we haven't
developed anything yet
after knight t6 he can play knight f5
and offer the nitrate
we've done the hard work of gaining
control over the square the threat is
stronger than its execution
we don't need to cement that control yet
we'll do that when the time is right
so let's be let's take this opportunity
to complete our development so that that
doesn't act as kind of a
counterweight to our positional
dominance how should we complete our
development
well if we think about it knight f3
is very simple bishop g5 is more
ambitious
i like bishop g5 it pins the knight
let's do it this is a very ambitious
move
we're keeping our king side undeveloped
but that's okay
then okay now what should we do guys
we can take this
well it depends on how we want to do
this
yeah let's go nuts let's go nuts
last game of an eight hour stream
well we need it we need to go nuts in a
very strategic way
um let's begin with a check with a
knight knight of six gen
we want to get him to take so that the
dark squares
around black's king will be terribly
weak and he does
now isn't this counter to what we wanted
to do initially which is to go 96 yes
but
a more juicy opportunity presented
itself which we're exploiting
how should we proceed this is clearly
total domination
and i want to finish this with a stylish
in style
let's start with a simple move queen 2
d2
now we need to figure out how to
continue breaking down
the defenses around black's king and
this is exactly where
our discussion earlier was pertinent we
can use our pawns
as battering ramps to bash down to
to to break down this this final the
maginot line the final line of defense
we do it by playing h4 we're gonna make
a really sexy move right now so
be prepared everybody particularly hot
mom lover everybody be prepared
we're going to do something cool if our
opponent permits
us okay
um
let's start by uh by getting this the
heck out of there
can we just get rid of this please yeah
but wait wait queen g5
is is fine but he doesn't have to take
our queen guys we'll
make this happen in a better way g4 get
out of here please thank you
band okay
now we want to be patient here there's
no hurry if we want to finish an amazing
style
let's start by pinning the sponsor that
h5 comes with even greater effect i hope
that he doesn't resign
and gives us a chance to do something
that i'm setting up here patiently
okay think about how to get this done
you guys will like this
hmm okay
now we just need one more little
component of this let's get our night
out
let's get our night out okay
okay now i'm thinking
this is where the supreme leader needs
to think
yes if this happens the way that i've
intended it to
this will be absolutely epic ladies and
gentlemen
there's an epic line that i've been
setting up
and i can't guarantee that it works
though let me think
all right this is this is actually
complex totally unnecessary
this is totally unnecessary and i you
shouldn't do this try this at home
but i'm trying to finish in style here
no no no no no no no no i was
calculating it he resigned simply
he resigned simply what uh what a
buzzkill
but it remains behind the scenes i had
to calculate it though i couldn't just
go for this the move is queen takes h6
check it's okay i'll analyze it
it's weird that he resigned here he
might have been listening i don't know
and what are we doing
what's the follow-up guys i'm not
actually sure if it works
what's the follow-up i should have just
done it
h5 and
it's not g5 g5 would be
counterproductive because it
relinquishes control he can even go king
h
but h5 threatens h takes g6 checkmate
okay now let's break down the defenses
if he takes
g takes h5 we push g5 this opens up the
bishop that's why we put it there
checkmate if knight takes h5
white to play and made in two moves
really pretty idea which will recur
notice that the only escape square for
the king is h7 so if we were to
force this g pawn out it would be
checkmate how can we do that
boom classic deflection and g5 checkmate
kind of cool and if uh
and that leaves us with a couple of
moves the first move which may seem to
be five head is knight takes f6
which in a roundabout way does defend
against g h takes g6
you guys might look at this and say it's
checkmate right i mean bishop defends
the pawn knight covers the square
is it checkmate
it's it's not checkmate because black
can block on h5 with his knight
either right if he blocks with this
knight
what does white do here folks
g5 is checkmate ignoring the night
that's me
if he blocks with this knight and i'm
sorry that it took me long
this is what i was calculating guys and
i really wish it would have happened
because that now i see that it works i
think all of this works
so there is a bit of an issue folks
because
if we take with a rook here if we do the
same thing remember
that the king now has an escape square
there's an issue look
very carefully the king has an escape
backward
to g7 and g8 that should make sense to
everybody
so we need to account for that and this
is where the notion of quiet moves comes
in
quiet moves are the hardest to see
because we're in this
we've sacrificed our queen we assume
that all of the moves have to be checked
but that's not true
we play e takes f6 not to win the knight
but to cover the g7 square and threaten
the checkmate
the line is still not over black plays
fg
to defend the knight with the pawn white
to play and win
this is stunning this line is stunning
and now
the final sequence here there's one more
defensive move to consider after this
one
not g5 g5 king h7 and kg escapes
nope that's a trap guys you might be
seeing this
but the king escapes no we start with
rook h5 and then we end with g5
checkmate i love this
yeah checkmate with a pun
every pawn contributing every every
piece contributing here
yeah cool stuff there's no defense here
now one move that was concerning me
is king h7 and this would have been the
most resilient
defensive move this would have been the
most resilient defensive move
uh and i was trying to find the
checkmate here
and couldn't convince myself that the
win was
uh that the wind was sufficiently
clear-cut here's what i calculated
and now i can convince myself let me
think for a second if you don't mind
so we start with taking
and we now have a situation where we've
got all these pieces in the attack
this night seems to be the big problem
if we could get rid of the night
we would open the floodgates how do we
get rid of the night
well we don't want to take it we want to
preserve this
influence on on the attack we go rook h7
and we want to take the knight the
knight is nowhere to go
he has to play knight takes f6 we take
back on f6
and we're threatening rick takes g7 and
that this is probably mating
but let's analyze let me see if the
engine actually approves
of queen takes h6 i'm checking
no it actually doesn't work because well
it does kind of work
h5 king h7 it says it's equal
amazing and this is the precise line
amazing it's it's equal
knight f5 shift f5
what an insane line but not particularly
beautiful as you guys can see it's
it's very computerised the black has to
give away the queen i think
or something to that effect crazy
computers
yeah but still um
beauty's beauty and uh i had a feeling
that there would be a defense which is
why i spent so long
verifying it i should have just made the
move but i hope you guys enjoy those
tactics
of course if you're playing a game
yourself just go h5 and win the game
h5 hg and win h6 queen h8
they do but that's life so
what happened here is of course this
movie six that's the very bad move you
gotta go d6 and knight f6 and castle
play a king's indian when you combine
these moves and you weaken squares like
this
there's no going back from that pawns
don't go backward and so you're in
immediate and massive trouble here
with respect to the dark squares which
we used as the jumping off point for the
final attack
let's go magnus carlson team okay
well mr magnus girls and team let's play
e4
let's play a4 he's on his team
well this is a molecular s moment c5
all right so we've been playing c3
sicilian
pretty much not pretty much exclusively
on the uh five minute speed run
but uh let's go for a topical let's go
for open sicilian
let's go for a topical line just in the
spirit of the candidates
yeah well hopefully he plays a poison
pun let's uh let's see if we can get the
fabulon
yeah i'm playing open sicilian which is
d4 that's the main line obviously open
sicilian
um and yeah 94
well he's playing into it so far whoa
coder with a 20 damner
that was insane all of a sudden the 20
coming in
hot from coder what is that
that's crazy that is an ultimate poggers
moment
oh my god i had to disable the alerts
thank you for the 20 coder i really
appreciate it
distracting me from the speed and i
couldn't do that earlier just getting
over 6 000 that's awesome okay
now this move most people who play the
open sicilian will not have seen this is
called the cotton hour variation
it's not particularly good now
those of you who played the night or
with any kind of regularity know that e5
itself is a common idea so the idea
itself is not that bad
but there's a very specific reason why
you play a6 and then you play e5 and
that reason
is what what
is available so b5 is available you
might assume that we want to go knight
b5 but
we don't because knight b5 black goes a6
and the knight has to go to a3
yeah so it's not knight b5
which doesn't leave us with much of a
choice it is actually bishop b5 now what
is the purpose of this check
the bottom line is that we are trying to
get the f5 square for our knight
to get the f5 script for an eye we
either have to trade the bishops which
will happen after bishop d7 or
if he would have played knight b to d7
that bishop would have been obstructed
so that's the entire reason you have to
play a six when you play the knight or
now we take the bishop and then we go
knight to f5 we have a beautiful square
for our knight there is theory in this
line black is not losing or anything
uh some people have played this and
there's a certain amount of theory here
but black is worse black is worse
because this knight is amazingly placed
the pawn on d6 is under fire and black
is
hardly able to breathe well if they go
g6 we take the pawn
also g6 is pretty weakening so we might
see that in the game
okay so queen b6
now we don't need to do anything about
the possibility of g6 because it weakens
his king side and we got to think about
where this knight could go
if it were attacked by the pawn so who
can offer to me a pathway for this
knight were
black to play g6 why aren't we why are
we not afraid of g6
where is the knight going to go
so h6 is possible but unnecessary if you
think about
the weak squares right d5 is the biggest
weakness in black's position
so just on a positional level we want to
go knight e3 and knight t5 and if black
and
like in the night or when white is able
to do this white's
in great shape so we can just castle we
don't have to
do anything about this threat he's
probably going to go g6
um and then we go 93 knight d5
establishing the knight on a beautiful
outpost
he goes rook to d8 instead okay
now um we have a poison pawn
situation here where the queen ties us
down to the b-2 pawn
but that's already a mistake in
reasoning thinking that oh
we have to play rook b-1 i think i would
see a lot of people here go rook b-1 or
b-3
and that would not be a terrible move
that would there would be some sense to
that but we'd actually don't have to do
that
the bottom line here is we are so
overwhelmingly ahead in development
and so active that we can
not just get away with sacrificing the
pawn but if black takes
it black is going to be in a lot more
trouble than if he doesn't so
on that note if we if this bond were to
be no concern
what would we do here what move what
active developing move could you offer
okay so bishop e3 attacks the queen and
encourages
it to take the pawn but i would argue
that there's a more active move a lot of
you
i've said this before are attracted to a
move because it creates a threat and
that's
legitimate to a degree but remember that
we want the e3 square to be sort of
reserved
potentially for the knight and that
bishop on e3 apart from attacking the
queen is not going to be doing much but
the bishop on g5
is going to be pinning the knight and
it's going to be paving the way
potentially for knight to d5
given that black can't move this night
the rook will hang
this is a much more active square he
takes immediately thinking that he's
hot s-h-i-t but watch what happens to
him
so what do we what do we do
there's many good moves there's many
ways to play this we need to recognize
that our knight hangs and the simplest
is of course to play knight to d5 and
centralize the knight using this pin
now hilariously if he takes the knight
we can take his rook but i don't think
we should
i think that we should keep our eyes on
the greater prize of just giving
checkmate his king is in such trouble
that taking the rook believe it or not
leads to unwanted complications what
move
can you guys spot after bishop takes
rook
that complicates the game unnecessarily
black is an intermediate move if you
look very carefully
this knight on d5 will be hanging but
that knight will be able to move to c3
and attack our queen and if our queen
moves well then the king will be able to
take the bishop we'll probably be fine
there
no no no but you guys are looking for
white i was asking for black
i was asking after bishop takes d8 find
black's intermediate move the response
to that is knight to c3
so we don't need to reinvent the wheel
here we simply keep the tension with
queen takes d5
threatening his rook and threatening the
d6 font
now uh it's time for us to collect the
harvest what do we do
now it's time for us to move in for the
kill
yeah check he's got to take we take we
threaten checkmate
there's only one way to stop checkmate
without giving stuff up okay now he
starts thinking when his move is forced
he has to play f6 now in such positions
when you're looking for maiden stuff
you have to always consider the drawback
of your opponent's move when your
opponent defends against the threat and
his king is as weak as it is
the the quickest shortcut to finding the
correct move is to ask yourself what
squares are no longer defended
you know what as a result of his last
move we can no longer
go queen e7 but what can we now do which
which was impossible previously
now some of you are considering rocate
to d1 that's a good move
but it is much better to first force the
king onto d8
right it can't go to f8 because we take
the knight and attack the rook at the
same time
and after king to da rook 81 is going to
be a lot stronger because it's going to
pin this knight and threaten checkmate
boom
obviously if he takes the bishop we take
his knight and that's mate
so he's just probably going to go to
rook c7 and then we have a
very nice uh move on top of that
so the attack is okay he plays correctly
queen b5
that's i'm pretty impressed actually all
right
now we need to consider uh you know we
need to look at the candidate moves just
be methodical
it's the game is not over yet we have to
be accurate
now a lot of you are calculating bishop
takes f6 so let's calculate bishop takes
f6
gf6 queen takes f6 he can't take the
queen because of the pin
so you might conclude that you win the
rook but
if you look a little bit more carefully
you will notice that he
has king c7 and the rooks connect we're
not able to take the rook
so instead we should look at other ways
to involve more pieces in the attack
okay so you might come up with the idea
let's double our rooks
but a slow move like rook d3 might not
be
fast enough because he takes the bishop
but as coder indicates rook to d5
circumvents that problem because it
occurs with tempo
you guys might say okay rook d7 queen d7
didn't work because
because rook d the d1 square is
undefended okay now we go rook d1 of
course
doubling our rooks and his knight is
toast now he has to go rook c7
to which we can of course respond then
bishop takes f6
so the tempe are important and you might
say well isn't it lucky that you
just happen to have this move rook t5
well that's just what happens when
you're attacking
now let's try to be accurate rook takes
d7
absolutely possible completely winning
but the king escapes to b8 and we're
gonna have to finish him off there
is there anything that we can start with
which perhaps
eases our task do we do we have to take
yeah let's give him a check first send
the king back to d8
yep then we can take on d7
force the queen trade and the king will
be forced to remain in the center
and we'll just start snagging all of his
pawns
but we'll also take a look at some other
moves after kingdom maybe we'll find a
faster win
there's no mate here directly bishop f6
gf6 doesn't quite cut the trick here
doesn't quite do the trick because again
queen f6 king c7 and i don't see the
continuation there
so in such a situation i wouldn't
reinvent the wheel
i would simply say okay we have three
minutes on the clock
maybe there's crazy moves like rook
takes e5 using all the pins
maybe just come back to e3 that's
another thing to consider but why
why is this necessary when we can just
win the night his position is utterly
paralyzed
he won't be able to move his rook at the
end because we'll go rook to d8 check
and win the other rook
so we just take drop the bishop and
enjoy our life
thank you coder and i haven't if we
really wanted to be five feet about this
if we really wanted to squeeze the most
let's consider where the bishop would be
best placed in the long term
now at some point we want to move this
rook aside
to pave the way for the other rook
piggies on the seventh
one way that occurs to me is to cover
the seven square with our bishop
and as you guys are pointing out i'm
pretty impressed this would not quite do
the trick although it's still
possible bishop all the way back to c1
so we could swing it to a3
and pave the way for rookie 7. how do i
find
how do i know to look for this well we
have a choice of where to put the bishop
you just got to consider the long term
plan here what do you want to accomplish
well you know that you want to move the
circuit side and play rook d7 that's a
common pattern
and you know that e7 is a dark square we
have a dark squared bishop
just got to connect the dots here
always play bishop c1 yeah that's always
a nice move check
and our bishop participates in the
checkmating scheme which i really like
and rook d it is me that's really nice
that's really really nice magnus
carlsen's team has been vanquished
boom okay and we're 1500 on our
10-minute speed run officially
all right
obviously it's easier with pins i'm not
pretending this is easy in the long
in just the grand scheme of things but
still i think that people are capable of
finding this if they put their mind to
it
that was really nice yeah no guys this
is gonna be the last game because i'm
i'm absolutely wiped okay
so let's but let's analyze so we have an
e5
and this is the cotton hour so bishop b5
bishop d7 again
okay if knight c6 then we take twice and
win
if knight b to d7 then knight f5 with
the same problem
that pawn is incredibly weak
bishop d7 we take first and then knight
f5 i mean you're welcome to bribe me i i
appreciate all the subs but this is
probably gonna be the last game now i
if i remember correctly the the theory
of this line goes queen takes d7
and after knight f5 those of you with
sharp tactical vision will notice
that black does have a tactic in this
position which may seem to
justify all of black's play what is it
knight takes c4 knight takes e4
and this removes the defender from the
knight
and if knight takes e4 then well you can
get this and take on d6
that's not particularly impressive black
will just get his pieces out and attack
the queen
but i have to update my own theoretical
knowledge
in such situations you look for
desperado sacrifices like if you're
already losing this knight how can we
give this knight away to make the most
damage to black's position and then this
comes to mind knight g7
and this really damages black's king
side d5
and now then i can move back to g3 and
then h5 i'm pretty sure this is a bad
position for black that's how the
theoretical line goes
so it's interesting some people play
like this with black
but if you know what you're doing you're
going to get a good position but he
takes with a knight which i'm pretty
sure is a big mistake
because after nine at five now our
knight is permanently established here
or at least on a good square and again
if g6
then we go knight e3 this knight swings
around to this incredible
central outpost and if he develops his
bishop it's biting on granite which is
another reason why combining e5 and g6
is rarely a good idea
he should have done something like this
the game goes on
it's not over over but positionally it
essentially is now what is the purpose
of bishop e3 the purpose is to stop
knight b6 because then we'll take with
the bishop and who can tell me on the
basis of some of the games i've already
shown you
how should we meet knight f6 this
attempt to trade off the knights what
should white do thank you
nm ramirez for the tier one
if you understand the positional
implications of this
now c4 is tempting but you guys are mis
misunderstanding the
the zen of this output it's the fact
that it's a knight that's particularly
important
this is fine you have an amazing
position here
don't get me wrong but what you really
want is to keep this knight on d5
the only way to do that is to go bishop
g5 that's the typical idea
trade the bishop for the knight and get
a very classic knight against bad bishop
position now you can play c4 to your
heart's content and double on the d
file but everybody should be able to see
the incredible domination that the
knight yields
not to men not to say that you know this
would be bad
this is a good bishop against that
bishop but i always like keeping a
knight on that outpost when possible
but if you can't then that's okay you
shouldn't despair
okay so anyways
in the game rook d it happens we
determine intuitively that it's okay to
sack the pawn we drop our knight on d5
again if we take the rook instead
automatically
it's a situation where two pieces are
hanging at the same time and
i always remind this to my students if
you have a situation where one of your
pieces is hanging one of your opponent's
thesis is saying you look for two things
you look for desperado sacrifices
and you look for intermediate moves can
your opponent move his piece that's
hanging and attack one of your pieces
that's a dangerous spot to be in because
now your queen is attacked and the
bishop is attacked
this is not great thank you anna ramirez
gifting to pugsley
white's probably still better here
somehow but
why deal with this when you can just go
queen takes d5
and i read this in decision making
theory not chess related but
you know one of the key like ideas when
making a decision
is to consider whether you've not
omitted one of the options
you may think there are two options but
maybe there's a third
and that often happens when you go for
something to win material
your initial idea might have been to
take
on d8 and then you might start panicking
if you see knight c3 and like oh no i
made a mistake
but if you see the bigger picture here
you'll notice how much white's
dominating over black's pieces you're
only down to pawn
so it's basically a no-brainer now if he
goes f6 then this is checkmate
he goes rick c8 we take the pawn
threaten checkmate
he has to defend it he weakens e6 bring
a rook and threatening mate
if he defends like this this comes in
boom boom is a fork and here's another
funny thing
yeah he should go king c8 here but now
we just take all those pawns
why not why why the f rook because i
didn't want this rook to be dead weight
i didn't want
his queen to be tied to our rook in case
we have to move our rook at some point
i wanted to make sure that this rook
wouldn't be in the crosshairs of the
queen if that makes sense
boom boom he correctly goes queen b5 but
now we go rook d5 doubling with tempo
now if you went queen c6 an instructive
move here
what should white do
who can spot the correct continuation
here would like without this next move
everything would have fallen apart
yeah so you guys are quickly spotting
the correct idea which is to play rook
to d6 you have to make sure that you're
doubling with tempo
and to do that you have to do something
about
the queens now this move is very fancy
i'm glad you spotted it kevin but black
can just take your bishop
right and if you go like this then rook
c7 comes black is holding things
together so
the simplest is to go rook d6 and then
rook d1
in the game he lets us do this
immediately and now queen d6 sending the
king back and then trading
bishop c1 bishop a3 the final maneuver
resulting in checkmate that was a nice
game i think it was an instructive game
which featured both positional concepts
and tactical concepts and now you see
the importance if you play in the night
or
of not forgetting to play a6
um what classical games well there's a
book by irving chernov
old book called logical chess move by
move which is essentially a
compilation of important classical games
i would direct you to that to that book
which i've recommended to some students
before i haven't read it myself but
i know that it has a really really good
games you can also do a search on
chessgames.com for classical games
and uh you know it'll give you a nice
list that you can analyze on your
own but yeah
logical chess move by move okay guys and
with that it's been a five hour stream
i would do an encore but i i really
really do want to hit the sack
um for now because i have another busy
day tomorrow you're very welcome jay
brain but
before i go um i want to thank everybody
again
from the bottom of my heart for the our
from for the uh incredible support all
right guys well i'm sorry but it's
it really has been i i've taught all day
and i streamed in the morning so i'm
i'm human i gotta get a little bit of
sleep
uh and i know you understand but uh
thank you everybody for the
the massive subscriptions for the for
the incredible support
we're again over six thousand uh it's
great for us to be maintaining that i
appreciate it
um played some pretty pretty solid chest
today i think so i'm pretty happy with
that as well
i'll see you guys tomorrow